il
moi
à
haguenau
vous avez le téton qui ça
je fais ce qu'il te plaît fermez vous
pouvez chanter on a toutes les paroles
on va a lancé ce qu'on relance la
musique peau soit vous êtes de la
famille de julien courbet bonsoir lui je
veux même pas le regarder non mais alors
on lance à partir du refrain avec les
paroles tout le public avec nous chez
vous aussi c'est parti
cas pas là
je vois tous les six mois
allez
avec moi
je ne sais pas
moi
sans abri
jean
encore
m
il boit
j'aime bien
duffar
merci
merci beaucoup attendaient
jules a dû lâcher
si je peux me permettre j'ai
l'impression que vous avez qui fait
écouter je ne cache pas un certain
plaisir c'est le nul lentement mais un
moment donné j'aurais bien fait de
julien est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
pour touche pas à mon poste ce soir 30
secondes comme si vous étiez à l'époque
de sans aucun doute mais comme ça il ya
un problème bt fond d'un plat salé
mettez moi allez allez du sud pourrait
s'il vous plaît vous le cabinet du
préfet madame je suis
oui madame je suis juillet au bc tout à
fait sérieux non mais on voudrait juste
rien pourquoi les canalisations n'ont
pas été posées madame j'avais un garçon
sérieux je pose une question sérieuse
je vous passe l avocat spécialisé
l'adorent à l'asile
c'est un scandale julien ces gens sont
des millions s'occupe pas d'eux c'est
une injure à la dignité de la femme
écoutez le témoignage de cet homme adam
qui vit son zoo monsieur pokora peuvent
expliquer au préfet s'il vous plaît aux
vous feriez mieux d'écouter ce qui dit